hi i'm christopher hines today we're
going to talk about sparring
in aikido
[Applause]
[Music]
all right guys so today we're going to
be talking about sparring in aikido and
this is a really
contentious subject right so lots of
people have a problem with this
i think there's a ton of reasons why we
have these problems with sparring
one of the biggest issues and it's it's
honestly a hard issue to see is that
sparring literally means struggle and
aikido is a martial art that attempts to
not
struggle with anything so the very act
of sparring in lots of ways
is the antithesis of what we want to do
in aikido and perhaps why the founders
said that we shouldn't have that kind of
competition in aikido so one of the many
reasons probably actually
but so that's one of the inherent
problems however iqr does have some
struggle methods
and for those struggle methods we do
need to have some kind of sparring
practice
and i'll show you today how you can have
a sparring practice for those parts
another thing to understand is in order
to get better at things you do have to
have some kind of
live training method so in order to
become proficient at doing aikido we
have to have some kind of live training
and the trick is the live training can't
be sparring because aikido's not about
struggle it's about something else so
how do we mix all that together so i'm
gonna talk a bunch about that today
we're gonna see if we can suss some of
those problems out i'm gonna call josh
and maya out here
and we're gonna go to work for you guys
josh maya
all right so talking about sparring
people always want to know about
sparring out of sparring work
it's a it's a difficult subject to
discuss in aikido because
sparring is about struggle struggle is
what makes you
better at things but the idea of ikey is
to never
struggle so how do we get good at
something
when the way to get good at that thing
is actually the antithesis
of the something we're trying to do this
is mind-blowing right so this is
outrageous how we gonna do this
so uh i've spent my life trying to
figure out this subject and i have some
answers for you
maybe you'll like the answers maybe you
won't the most important thing though is
it doesn't matter if we have the answers
it matters if
you have the answers so you need to do
this stuff
you doing it is the goal right it
doesn't matter that aikido has some kind
of superhero who can do
it we had that superhero years ago right
his name was maura ueshiba he apparently
could do really amazing things that
impressed everyone
cool but the rest of us can't do this
stuff so how do we get good at it that's
what this is about so
the whole reason i'm making videos is so
you guys can do this stuff and get
better at it and then we can have
discourse right so we can talk back and
forth about how we all get better at it
okay
so that aside um how do i suggest that
we start to get better at it
so the first thing you have to
understand is aikido's broke into two
categories
one category is ikea
the other category is kumiuchi
so there's a bunch of different things
we do in aikido there's a main division
of three one is uh ashi or tai sabaki
how you use your body
and then we have uh ikea and we have
kumiuchi
so kumiuchi means struggle methods it's
an old word back in the day in japan
that was synonymous with
jiu jitsu right same kind of things it
means how we're gonna struggle back and
forth
and wrestle around right so that's what
sparring would be some kind of
struggling methods
now aikido actually doesn't want to
emphasize the kumiuchi but we have to
have the kumiuchi because sometimes we
can't make good
ikea key is the ability to make an
energetic harmony right so how to fit
our energies together
and i've said in other videos a
conversation is a good way to think
about it
how can we have some kind of energetic
reaction instead of a physical one
and that energetic reaction is going to
keep us safest right so
energetic reaction can mean
understanding what someone's plotting in
their head
or to be friendly to someone off the bat
so we never get into an argument
or to keep my distance from someone so
they can't actually hurt me if they were
to try to
hurt me and to keep a good position and
all this stuff that's the main body of
aikido practice that's
mostly what aikido practice is about
however
when we we look at what's going on it's
easiest to see
kumiuchi stuff right so in this video
i'm gonna have to talk to you guys about
what kumiuchi is and what eye key is
and and how we can practice for both of
those but kumiuchi
will more likely lend itself to sparring
and right now i'm gonna teach you
the first three stage progression i
started using at this school
in order to get my guys sparring and
this deals with a bunch of serious
issues
that you will have as an aikido school
initially beginning to spar
one of the issues is teacher ego right
so i i hate to tell you guys this but if
you've been the teacher you're the black
belt awesome teacher and everyone super
respects you in the school
you are probably very scared to start
sparring and fall on your ass and look
dumb
it's it's a real legit fear i totally
understand that fear
especially if you haven't had the luck
of being able to do a bunch of stuff in
the past right so when i started working
with my guys on sparring all the time
luckily i had already trained mma and
done some stick fighting and
done a bunch of brazilian jiu jitsu and
submission wrestling so i was
comfortable in that and so i just kind
of always kind of kept skewing stuff to
that
so i would look good right but you're
going to have to get past that right
you're going to have to accept that like
no one in aikido is very good at this
stuff in a live situation and so the way
we get good at it
is to train it so first thing you have
to get over is teacher ego right so
that's a real problem
this drill will kind of address teacher
ego and you'll see how we can start to
develop some skills
and probably if you've done a lot of
aikido you'll catch on a lot quicker
than your students anyway so
you'll probably stay ahead of them and
you won't have to worry too much okay
second thing this deals with is student
injury right so
student injury is a major thing we have
to worry about
and let me tell you i've had many issues
with this because you get a group of
guys
who starts doing live training and they
start getting reckless and they hurt
themselves a bunch and then your guys
can't spar
all the time anymore and you're back to
doing forms training and then when you
think about going back to live training
it's like
are we all going to get hurt again
what's going on so we have to deal with
student injury student injury is a real
concern
so a we have teacher ego how do we deal
with that second we have
student injury how do we deal with this
issue so i'm going to teach you my three
stage progression to start you guys off
with sparring and then we'll go from
there and we'll get more complicated
drills as we go
so we're gonna need some tools all right
so now we have
a wooden knife and that's we're gonna
start off with and we're gonna put josh
in the kumiuchi position because today
josh is representing
kumiuchi struggle right all right so
first part of this drill
we're going to start from a catate dori
grab so maya's going to grab
grab josh in a catoptery all right so
this should look really familiar we do
this in aikido schools all the time
what is it good for well this drill
already starts to hash out what's good
for
what it's good for right josh had a
weapon in his hand he needed to use the
weapon
she's grabbed his hand to stop him from
using the weapon what's gonna happen
with this all right now
the first part we're training is we're
training maya's ability to keep a good
grip
on josh and have a flexible body right
so she can have a flexible body when
she's doing this
so maya's not allowed to move her feet
and josh is allowed to move his feet and
what josh is going to do is move around
maya
and try and find the breaking points of
her grip right so
where are those breaking points in her
grip and right now what josh is doing is
he's taking her right to the edge every
time and then he's letting her set back
up to a basically a balanced position
right so
as he's moving through that's all he's
doing okay
good very good all right now let's talk
about what this drill is doing all right
this drill is one it's starting to train
maya
how to use her our flexibility in her
body to compensate for what josh is
doing so
she's not working on grip strength or
anything she's just using flexibility in
her body to track what josh is up to
okay second thing we're training josh is
where
he can move that her grip's right about
to break so he's learning
what positions he can be in that her
grip is about to break
alright now this is a mellow practice
right and josh
not to try and break her grip all the
time but try and get right to the edge
of where her grip breaks
and then stop there and move to a new
position
now maya's also told not to move her
feet so what happens is we get a very
a semi-live practice starting to happen
it's not really live but
we're starting to get these guys moving
in that kind of way and exploring and
learning and thinking about things and
so this is a good
practice to start people off no one's
going to get hurt doing this
and people can start to understand
what's going on plus at this point if
our egos start to kick in too much
we can say hey that's not the practice
right you know so if you're trying to
super hold down or lock with two hands
or something crazy well that's just not
the practice right so mellow out
so get you guys doing something like
this okay now second part of this
progression starts in the exact same
position
the catatoy grip and now what's going to
happen is
josh is not allowed to move his feet but
he's going to move as explosively as he
can and try and break maya's grip
okay now maya is allowed to move
her feet in this drill so as josh moves
mike can try to compensate right okay so
as he goes through
he's trying to get free maya's trying to
stick with him
excellent all right great okay so now
what this half of the drill this part of
the drill is doing
is it's doing the opposite sets for each
of these guys right now maya's learning
to move her feet with her flexible body
whereas before she wasn't she was just
depending upon the flexible body but
there's a part where your body's gonna
break right so your grip will break
and and that's what we explored before
but now maya can move her feet to
compensate for that
we're also teaching josh to go right for
the kill right how to explode and pop
his hand free so
now josh is doing different than he did
before not trying to find the perfect
angle but just trying to use explosive
action
this also means that mai is having to
train for this explosive action as well
so now we're getting these guys doing
something that is truly live
it's truly an explosion to try and
escape and mine's trying to compensate
for that right so now you can see
we filled in the gaps the problems we
were having with the second practice
again though we have basically a pretty
safe practice
now this practice will bruise your ego
some but
josh has got such a nice advantage that
you just got to accept the guy with the
knife is probably going to get free most
the time so
if you if your ego's getting too bruised
you can go well it's so stacked against
me that
you know and and look the truth is
you're going to have to get over your
ego eventually and that's what we're
building towards but it's going to hurt
at first
so we're trying to ease you into that
okay so that's the second stage on this
progression
third stage on this progression is
they're going to start in an uh catacly
grip again okay now
josh is allowed to move and i would
suggest that you tell your students the
first
times you do this he's not going to try
to go as explosively as before but
but he still should be moving pretty
good and maya is allowed to move so
they're both allowed to move their feet
wherever they want and josh is simply
going to get free
or try to get free and maya's going to
try to get uh to stay with him right
so here we go
excellent all right good okay now we
start to have a really fun practice and
that's a very fun practice
that's live it's got all kinds of live
stuff going on now is it extreme
absolutely not extreme you're probably
going to get zero injuries off of this
right
it's pretty reasonable the injuries you
get will be stupidity injuries right so
people jabbing themselves
in the head with the knife because
they're not used to moving with a knife
people pulling the knife into their body
because they're stupid and not used to
doing that
these will be things that suss out all
the beginning problems you're going to
have
so this is a really basic practice to
get through
i would recommend if you've never done
any sparring in your school to work on
this three-stage progression
for a while right so get your students
doing it until it's really comfortable
and so you can generally just jump into
stage three and no one's going to be
going crazy
uh and attacking each other now when
we're talking about like high stress
situations you will need that to get
good
but at first you don't want to have a
lot of that because these guys aren't
used to taking the kind of explosive
action they're going to hurt each other
so
don't let them hurt each other at first
ease them into it this three-stage
progression is really
good okay now this three-stage
progression once you've done it for a
while this can begin to get into what we
call kaishiwaza
and so when i started working with the
guys in the garage years ago after they
could all do this
pretty well then what i did was i
transitioned us into what we call
kaishiwaza
in japanese kaishi means to turn over so
the idea of this practice is to turn
over who's doing what that's the actual
goal in this practice
is to turn it over turn it over turn it
over now again i have a little
progression that we use to get us up to
a full kaishiwaza
and this progression is built to get
skills as we go
in the safest manner possible so we're
not getting a ton of injuries right so i
don't want a ton of injuries from our
guys
okay kaisuaz is going to start again
from this practice okay
now we could say the beginning practice
was a kaishi was a practice the one we
just did the stage three for the last
practice but it's really not it's more a
hadoke practice an escaping practice
but now we're actually going to add the
idea of kaishi so as they're moving and
just move kind of slow right now so
so this is just so i can talk about it
you guys can kind of watch them move
okay
what's going to happen in this is maya
is allowed to try and get
basic disarms so as they're moving
around maya's tried to work a disarm now
the second she works at this arm she
begins the practice just like before
they go to a top they grip and then she
begins to try and get free
and as they're working this josh tries
to get the disarm
okay so he's working around working
around ah now josh got the knife now he
comes in right right so sorry we're
going to be at a top door every time
right so this is our basic practice
right and
and they're going a couple steps ahead
but that's okay all right so you guys
see the idea all right
so that's what's going to happen with
this practice is that uh we start in the
katakedori every time
the hadoki stuff's still happening so
the guy with the knife is trying to make
hidoki
but the other person is allowed to go
into disarms now what you want to start
to watch at this phase and we'll get
into this but at this
phase we shouldn't see maya going into
any kind of morote for extended periods
of time so show morote maya for extended
period of time right so see if she's got
two on one
and then what's gonna tend to happen is
from this you're gonna get this person
who's got a lot of ego they're gonna
start to go like
this and hold it for a long time and
then josh is trying to make hidoki and
this person's just doing this
and nothing's happening right so that's
not skill developing right it's just
force developing right and we can do
that later it's a fair part of this
practice but in the beginning watch that
right
so as they're going and josh is trying
to make a sudoki and mine's trying to
get the disarm if maya goes into some
kind of locked up position at some point
it's like hey hey that's not the
practice guys go ahead and and let go of
that right
okay also a thing you're gonna have to
work watch for in this practice is
people
not going back to the katate dory grip
so
if josh makes his hidoki in this right
so he is really trying to get free the
whole time
then what he does is he plays this game
uh this is nothing quite the game this
is what i mean so josh makes his hedoki
okay and then he goes come on get the
knife come on come on i'm oh
oh i'm a knife fighting guy right okay
so this is what tends to happen a lot is
you want to play out a fantasy and
pretend like you're steven seagal in the
movies okay
you're not stephen segall in the movies
right this is not a movie it's a dojo
and you're training
and so that's not what's going on so you
got to watch that tendency to do that
so that's why at this stage they're just
putting their arm back out there and the
other person gets to grab it and we
don't go
until they've got to this stage
sometimes if i get guys who are really
amped up
i will tell one of them to get to say go
right so for example if they're in that
tate dory maya gets to say when they go
go then they're working josh is trying
to get free
maya's trying to find disarms just like
that josh gets free gives her back the
hand
exactly what happens all right good so
you see that's this basic practice okay
now how do we begin to amp this up
okay once they can do the successfully
we get nice clean disarms and there's a
back and forth a little back and forth
happening then what we're going to do is
the ability to switch the knife
for this guy right okay so as they're
going here
uh she's got josh josh starts moving
okay josh can switch
knife hands anytime he wants okay so now
he switched the knife hand
and now maya's trying to get it with the
new knife hand right going back and
forth back and forth back and forth josh
switch knife hands again
okay good all right now at this stage is
when we can start to talk about
playing this knife fighting game right
okay now
that will come up for josh a lot because
or maya whoever's got the knife right
when she switches knife hands
okay there now she could try and keep
josh away which would be a successful
strategy if the goal was to train maya
to be a murderer with knives but right
now that's not the goldenest drill
okay so what maya is going to do instead
of just giving him a katate
she's going to start to slowly shoot her
hand in there and this is going to give
josh the ability to get a basic defense
and go back into working his disarms
right so that's what we're going back
and back fourth through fourth okay
so you can see this is the idea the
practice is that every time you get an
escape you're going to kind of give it
back to them now look
that's not the ultimate we're going to
get to the ultimate where you're really
working that knife
but in this set of drills we can't work
on that so it's another important thing
when you start teaching people
how to how to have a live practice is
you can't just go to the ultimate
10 right away right so we got to build
up right and this is going to give us
the skills
and the ability to stay injury-free
which is what we want
for our practice here right okay once
we're
switching around then we can start to
add in other things and this is where
it's going to get real exciting for
everybody
but you have to have guys who are going
to be pretty sane at this point right so
if anyone's flipping out you relegate
them to a lower level practicing don't
let them go to this right and flipping
out means that they're crazy and they
think that they're some ninja and
they're trying to flip someone or punch
them or something crazy which is not
what this practice is right now okay
so in this next practice we're gonna
start in the exact same way but while
they're going they're allowed to use
any aikido techniques that facilitate
the goal let me say that again
facilitate
the goal now why i'm saying this is
because josh doesn't want to just throw
maya so he feels good about throwing
like oh cool
but if any techniques come up that
enable him
to get free and use the knife which is
the goal he wants to be free and
autonomous with the knife
then he can use that technique right so
if shionges or kokinagi's or koshinagas
or whatever come up
okay then they come up i'm going to get
out of here and we're going to see if we
can get these guys to do a few of those
[Music]
oh
is
[Music]
uh
boom
[Music]
big
okay so that is uh what we would call a
kaishi was a practice in our school it
just means a turnover practice it's
because
the objective is to turn that knife over
and the person with the knife is
trying to get free but it's not a
hadokey practice right an escaping
practice and we have those you can
definitely see those on on the videos
but that's not the main goal although
he's working it intermittently
and as he gets free pretty much kind of
just give it back to him you can give it
back to him with kind of a grandiose
strike so that way it's
pretty easy to deal with but the
objective is not to play knife fighter
right now right there will be other
drills to play knife fighter
but the the objective of this right now
is is just to learn these kinds of
skills which is turnover skills
this is a good practice it will get
heated at your dojo
you notice these guys did a good job of
flowing it's because they've done it for
a long time
it won't look like this at first in your
school so you want to get up to this
stage and once you get up to this stage
you can add harder practices right so
once they can regularly flow with each
other
then we can start to add more wrestling
practices naturally they're going to
want to go as fast and wrestle as much
as possible
with the other drills so you've got to
divorce them of that right so the idea
is always to train them to use
less force in training and more
technical skill
and eye key ability right so that's what
we're always trying to get towards is
that
they will naturally get to deal with
struggling all the times it's going to
happen right especially
new students come in it'll be great
because once you've got some students
who are trying to advance this when new
people come in
they're going to try all kinds of crazy
wrestling stuff and then you can you can
get the experience of dealing with that
from a flowing state
okay next i'm going to talk about my six
stage progression because i think it's
really useful so once you
want to start adding more wrestling in
we can work on the six stage progression
now we've already made a video on it so
i'm not going to talk about it at length
but uh in this set that that i think is
really good our starter three set
followed by a kaishiwaza practice
followed by the six stage progression to
me this is what i would recommend
for starting out your kumiuchi practice
right so
our struggle practice in aikido and this
is how you're going to develop those
basic skills
so the basic idea of this is josh is
going to have the stick here
maya is going to grab both sides of the
stick like this
the very first stage in this progression
is josh has a really loose grip
and she finds the best ways to get it
out second stages
josh holds it as hard as he can and maya
again tries to get it out trying to use
as little explosive powers
as possible third stage josh is going to
dynamically move his arm around so as
she moves
josh going to dynamically move that arm
around to try and stop her she tries to
get it free
fourth stage he's going to be able to
turn his grip over so as she's trying to
get it out of the hand he can turn his
grip over
and try and re-grab it okay fifth stage
josh is going to intermittently switch
hands so he's gonna go through and
intermittently switch hands so
as she moves through he's gonna get that
other hand in there only one hand at a
time he's gonna be able to switch to
keep a hold of that weapon
sixth and final stage once this starts
right so the second mine starts to move
then josh is going to add a second hand
and they're wrestling over the stick
let's see what that looks like
[Music]
time okay so that was the six stage
progression
uh you guys can link i'll put a link
right here
for you guys um that i've got a whole
video just talking about that six stage
progression going into it
but what's important is you notice at
the end of that six stage progression
they're actually
wrestling over the knife right so it's a
little bit more of an extreme practice
where they're actually
physically using as much force as they
can to get the weapon free
now that ideally is not good aikido in
fact a lot of times i'll refer to this
kind of stuff
as aikido adjacent because it's not
really the systematic approach that
aikido wants to use
we're only looking at a tiny fraction of
what is aikido when we're looking at
that stuff
but that is the way you'll have to train
kumiuchi so kumiuchi is sparring
grappling struggle stuff so we've got to
be able to get good at that in case our
ikey fails
but that's not where we should put the
majority of our practice if you want to
put the majority of your practice there
you should just study jiu jitsu right go
to a good jiu jitsu school or judo
school and work on that kind of stuff
because
if you want to just master that practice
those schools will be better at teaching
you that stuff than any aikido school
will
but aikido is teaching you to do it in a
brief moment so you can get free and
reset your aikido strategies
so this is going to be a two-parter in
the next series we'll talk about
eye key and and live practice for ikey
and why sparring practices don't really
work for that and why the majority of
your practice
shouldn't be sparring practices but you
guys will have to understand this stuff
in order to
have a complete view of aikido so this
stuff was about struggle and sparring in
aikido i hope it
illuminated it to you this is what i use
to get our school going right so that
three-stage starter progression is
really good
that slowly can turn into kaishiwaza
which is really good
and that can turn into that six stage
progression which will give us a lot of
skills when someone's actually
physically trying to wrestle and stop
you which will
give people experience with violent
serious action which is what we want
all right i'm christopher hine thanks a
lot stay tuned for part two